the CDC confirmed 10 new cases of the
rare polio like illness infecting people
across the country 72 people mostly
children have now been diagnosed with
acute flaccid myelitis or a fem in 24
states the CDC is also keeping a close
watch on the flu after the highest
number of deaths from the virus last
year since modern tracking began only on
CBS this morning we spoke to the
director of the Centers for Disease
Control dr. Robert Redfield at his
headquarters in Atlanta he told us he is
also worried about a pandemic like the
1918 Spanish flu which killed as many as
50 million people worldwide we lost more
children last year from flu deaths than
any year before since we started
recording and emerging majority of those
children that died were not vaccinated I
want to come back and argue that
immunization is one of the most critical
tools we have to eliminate diseases in
this case it's the most important tool
we having to minimize flu we were
approaching the 100th anniversary of the
Spanish flu which was devastating is
that possible in our modern age you know
people ask me what keeps me up at night
and the thing that keeps me up at night
is just what you brought out pandemic
flu so I think it's very possible and/or
at risk for another pandemic our best
preparation for that pandemic is to
optimize their response to seasonal flu
but John I think that is you know
remains a serious possibility president
Trump has mentioned twice in
conversations with Bill Gates that he
was thinking about a task force to look
into vaccines and whether there was a
downside to them or whether they caused
any illnesses has he ever talked about
that with you know have you ever thought
about maybe educating him about the
benefits of vaccines well the most
powerful tool we have to eliminate
disease is vaccination we're on the
verge of eliminating polio from the
world there's 22 cases of polio right
now how did we get on the verge
vaccination there has been this spike in
acute flaccid myelitis what do we know
about where it comes from and where do
you think this is headed well it's a
very serious condition it's a very rare
condition about one in a million
CDC has been working very
hard on this since 2014 to try to
understand causation etiology as we sit
here today we don't have understanding
of the cause and I've recently asked
again to put together a task force to
really try to look at where we're at and
what else could we do to try to solve
this problem the good news is that it
doesn't appear to be transmissible from
human to human we don't see clustering
in families I want to make it clear to
the American public it's not polio I
will say to the families that have had
this this is a you know it's a
devastating disease we recognize that
and we're gonna work then we figured out
you know we talked about a wide variety
of things and he you know he's quite
serious about that flu pandemic but he
also talked about antibiotics and the
overuse of them and how now because of
the global because we're all connected
how that that problem can come to us and
he talked about basically how it can
strip away all the advantages of
modernity because there could be strains
that come that we just can't combat with
current medications I like knowing
they're on top of it that they're really
paying attention they're on top of it
and they're one step ahead of what we're
all worried about that's absolutely
right and important to hear from them
yeah I get my flu shot